We've come a long way in this course.
>> Yeah.
>> Some of our students may be feeling
ecstatic that they built
these couple of apps.
>> Yeah.
Although some of them may be feeling
a little bit pensive because they
realize that there is a lot to learn.
>> There is, and
I can empathize with that feeling.
When I first started at Google,
I felt out of place.
I didn't know why they hired me.
I just felt like an impostor.
>> Like impostor syndrome?
>> Exactly, but then I realize that
other people also feel the same thing,
and that made me feel more at ease.
>> Wow, thanks for sharing.
Let's do the same thing for
our students next.
>> Okay.
>> Here are some Googlers sharing
their stories of feeling out of place.